you have co-authored several recent
papers that sort of weave beautifully
between the world of neuroscience and
artificial intelligence and this maybe
if we could can we just try to dance
around and talk about some of them maybe
tried to pick up the interesting idea as
a jump to your mind from memory so maybe
looking at we're talking about the
prefrontal cortex the 2018 I believe
paper called the prefrontal cortex as a
matter of reinforcement learning system
what is there a key idea that you can
speak to from that paper yeah the I mean
the key idea is about meta learning so
what is meta learning meta learning is
by definition a situation in which you
have a learning algorithm and the
learning algorithm operates in such a
way that it gives rise to another
learning algorithm in the in the
earliest applications of this idea you
had one learning algorithm sort of
adjusting the parameters on another
learning algorithm but the case that
we're interested in this paper is one
where you start with just one learning
algorithm and then another learning
algorithm kind of emerges out of the
kind of thin air I can say more about
what I mean by that I don't mean to be
you know spíritus yeah but that's the
idea of meta learning you you it relates
to the old idea and psychology of
learning to learn situations where you
you you have experiences that make you
better at learning something new like a
group a familiar example would be
learning a foreign language the first
time you learn a foreign language it may
be you know quite laborious and
disorienting and a novel but if you
let's say you've learned to two foreign
languages
the third foreign language obviously is
going to be much easier to pick up and
why because you've learned how to learn
you know how this goes you know okay I'm
gonna have to learn how to conjugate it
I'm gonna happen that's a that's a
simple form of
learning right in the sense that there's
some slow learning mechanism that's
giving that's helping you kind of update
your fast learning mechanism that that
makes you know so how from from our
understand from the psychology world
from a neuroscience honor our
understanding how motor learning works
might work in the human brain what what
lessons can we draw from that that we
can bring into the artificial
intelligence world
well yeah so we the origin of that paper
was in AI work that that we were doing
in my group we were we were looking at
what happens when you train a recurrent
neural network using standard
reinforcement learning algorithms but
but you train that network not just in
one task but you trained it in a bunch
of interrelated tasks and then you ask
what happens when you give it yet
another task in that sort of line of
interrelated tasks and and what we
started to realize is that a form of
meta learning spontaneously happens in
in recurrent neural networks and and the
simplest way to explain it is to say a
recurrent a recurrent neural network has
a kind of memory in its activation
patterns it's recurrent by definition in
the sense that you have units that
connect to other units that connect to
other units so you have sort of loops of
connectivity which allows activity to
stick around and be updated over time in
psychology we call in neuroscience we
call this working memory it's like
actively holding something in mind and
and and and so that memory gives the
recurrent neural network of dynamics
right the way that the activity pattern
evolves over time is inherent to the
connectivity of the recurrent neural
network okay so that's that's idea
number one now the dynamics of that
network are shaped by the connectivity
by the synaptic weights and those
synaptic weights are being shaped by
this reinforcement learning algorithm
that you're you know training the
network with
so the punchline is if you train a
recurrent neural network with a
reinforcement learning algorithm that's
adjusting its weights and you do that
for long enough the activation dynamics
will become very interesting right so
imagine imagine I give you a task where
you have to press one button or another
left button or right button and some
time and there's some probability that
I'm gonna give you an mm if you press
the left button and there's some
probability I'll give you an mm if you
press the other button and you have to
figure out what those probabilities are
just by trying things out but as I said
before instead of just giving you one of
these tasks I give you a whole sequence
you know I give you two buttons and you
figure out which one's best and I go
good job here's here's a new box two new
buttons you have to figure out which
one's best
good job here's a new box and every box
has its own probabilities and you have
to figure so if you train a neural net
recurrent neural network on that kind of
sequence of tasks the what happens it
seemed almost magical - to us when we
first started kind of realizing what was
going on the slow learning algorithm
that's justing the the synaptic weights
though those slow synaptic changes give
rise to a network dynamics that them
cell that you know the dynamics
themselves turn into a learning
algorithm so in other words you can you
can tell this is happening by just
freezing the synaptic weights saying
okay no more learning you're done here's
a new box figure out which button is
best and the recurrent neural network
will do this just fine there's no like
it figures out which which button is
best it trains transitions from
exploring the two buttons to just
pressing the one that it likes best in a
very rational way how is that happening
it's happening because the activity of
the name the activity dynamics of the
network have been shaped by this slow
learning process that's occurred over
many many boxes and so what's happened
is that this slow learning algorithm
that's slowly adjusting the weights is
changing the dynamics of the network the
activity dynamics into its own learning
algorithm and as we were as we were kind
of realizing that this is the thing
it just so happened that the group that
was working on this included a bunch of
neuroscientists and it started kind of
ringing a bell for us which is to say
that we thought this sounds a lot like
the distinction between synaptic
learning and activity synaptic memory
and activity based memory in the brain
and it also reminded us of recurrent
connectivity that's very characteristic
of prefrontal function so there this is
this is kind of why it's good to have
people working on AI that know a little
bit about neuroscience and vice-versa
because we started thinking about
whether we could apply this principle to
neuroscience and that's where the paper
came from so the kind of principle of
the the recurrence they can see in the
prefrontal cortex then you start to
realize that it's possible to for
something like an idea of a learning to
learn emerging from this learning
process as long as you keep varying the
environment sufficient exactly so so the
the the kind of metaphorical transition
we made to neuroscience was to think
okay well we know that the prefrontal
cortex is highly recurrent we know that
it's an important locus for working
memory for active activation based
memory
so maybe the prefrontal cortex supports
reinforcement learning in other words
you what is reinforcement learning you
take an action you see how much reward
you got you update your policy of
behavior maybe the prefrontal cortex is
doing that sort of thing strictly in its
activation patterns it's keeping around
a memory in its activity patterns of
what you did how much reward you got and
it's using that that activity-based
memory as a basis for updating behavior
but then the question is well how did
the prefrontal cortex get get so smart
in other words how did it where did
these activity dynamics come from how
did that program that's implemented in
the recurrent dynamics of the prefrontal
cortex arise and one answer that became
evident in this work was well maybe
maybe the mechanisms that operate on the
synaptic level
which we believe are mediated by
dopamine are responsible for shaping
those dynamics so this may be a silly
question but because this kind of
several temp temporal of classes of
learning are happening and the learning
to learn is emerges can it just can you
keep building stacks of learning to
learn to learn learning to learn to
learn to learn to learn because it keeps
I mean basically abstractions of more
powerful abilities to generalize of
learning complex rules yeah
is this that's overstretching the this
kind of mechanism well what at one of
the one of the people in AI who started
thinking about meta learning from their
very early on you're gonna submit Hueber
sort of cheekily suggested i think it is
it may have been in his PhD thesis that
we should think about meta meta meta
meta meta meta learning you know that
that's really that's really what's going
to get us to true intelligence certainly
there's a poetic aspect to it and it
seems interesting and correct that that
kind of level of abstraction would be
powerful but is that something you see
in the brain this kind of is it useful
to think of learning in these meta meta
meta way or is it just meta learning
well one thing that really fascinated me
about this mechanism that we were
starting to look at and you know other
groups started talking about very
similar things at the same time and and
then a kind of explosion of interest in
metal earning happened in the AI
community shortly after that I don't
know if we had anything to do with that
but but I was gratified to see that a
lot of people started talking about meta
learning one of the things that I like
about the kind of flavor of meta
learning that we were studying was that
it didn't require anything special it
was just if you took a system that had
some form of memory that the function of
which could be shaped by
pick your RL algorithm then this would
just happen yes right I mean there there
there are a lot of forms of there are a
lot of meta learning algorithms that
have been proposed since then that are
fascinating and effective in in their
you know in their domains of application
but they're you know they're engineer
they're they're things that you had to
say well see if we wanted meta learning
to happen how would we do that here's an
algorithm that would but there's
something about the kind of meta
learning that we were studying that
seemed to me special in the sense that
it wasn't an algorithm it was just
something that automatically happened if
you had a system that had memory and it
was trained with a reinforcement
learning algorithm and and in that sense
it can be as meta as it wants to be
right there's no limit on how abstract
the the meta learning can get because
it's not reliant on a human engineering
a particular metal learning algorithm to
get there and and that's I I also I
don't know I guess I hope that that's
relevant in the brain I think there's a
kind of beauty in the in in the ability
of this emergent the emergent aspect of
it yeah it's the staging yard exactly
it's something that just it just happens
in a sense in a sense you can't avoid
this happening if you have a system that
has memory and the function of that
memory is shaped by reinforcement
learning and this system is trained in a
series of interrelated tasks this is
gonna happen you can't stop it as long
as you have certain properties maybe
like of a current structure to you have
to have memory it actually doesn't have
to be a recurrent neural network when a
paper that I was honored to be involved
with even earlier used a kind of slot
based memory you remember the title just
it was memory augmented neural networks
I think it what idle was meta learning
in memory augmented neural networks and
and you know it was the same exact story
you know if you have a system with
memory here it was a different kind of
memory but the function of that memory
is
shaped by reinforcement learning here it
was the real opinion oh the reads and
writes that occurred on this slot based
memory this yeah this'll just happen and
and and so this but this brings us back
to something I was saying earlier about
the importance of the UH the environment
the this this will happen if the system
is being trained in a setting where
there's like a sequence of tasks that
all share some abstract structure you
know sometimes we talk about tasks
distributions and that's something
that's very obviously true of the world
that humans inhabit we're we're
constantly like if you just kind of
think about what you do every day you
never you never do exactly the same
thing that you did the day before but
everything that you do is sort of has a
family resemblance it shares a structure
with something that you did before and
so you know the the real world is sort
of you know saturated with this kind of
this property it's an endless variety
with endless redundancy and that's the
setting in which this kind of meta
learning happens and does seem like
we're just so good at finding just like
in this emergent phenomena you describe
we're really good at finding that
redundancy finding those similarities
this the family resemblance some people
call it sort of what is it Melanie
Mitchell was talking about analogies so
we were able to connect concepts
together in in this kind of way and in
in this same kind of automated emergent
way which if there's so many echoes here
of psychology neuroscience and obviously
now with onion reinforcement learning
with recurrent neural networks at the
core
you